[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
taking a look at a couple of things
first how was harry potter so rich where
did he get
all of that money from secondly we're
going to be taking a look at the books
films in order to determine if harry
ended up holding on
to all of that wealth we know that in
the philosopher's stone he's got a vault
full of it but what came of it all
harry's a good guy
did he spend it philanthropically did he
spend it greedily
though it's mentioned a few more times
in the books his wealth isn't ever
really revisited in the films
i've touched on this topic a little bit
in the past but today's video is going
to be a
more extensive look at the wealth of
harry potter if we go all the way back
to the year 2001
when the philosopher's stone was first
released we get our first glance the
riches of harry potter on screen
we had read about it in the books but
this was our first
real opportunity to see his stacks of
gold with our own eyes
when hagrid brings harry to vault 687 he
sees his fortune for the first time
and it appears to be a completely
ludicrous amount of gold
so what gives where did it come from now
it shouldn't be a surprise to anyone
there's certainly a class system
even in the magical world on one end of
the spectrum there are the weezies
who are quite obviously portrayed to be
a bit poor and on the other side
there are malfoy's who openly and
arrogantly flaunt their wealth
but the truth is that the mouthways
aren't the only wealthy family
in the wizarding world in fact harry's
family the potters
did quite well for themselves but we
know that it didn't originate from lily
and james
harry's parents as they were only 21
years old when they died
we also know that it didn't originate
from lily's side as her parents were
muggles
so who helped the potter family to amass
all of their wealth
it turns out that it all started with
the founding patriarch of the potter
family
linford of stinchcombe a 12th century
potioneer
who was quite successful in his field
linford was responsible for creating
remedies
still used to this day including
skelegro
which interestingly enough was actually
used on harry in the chamber of secrets
the function of skelegro is quite simple
and that is to heal bones
it can repair broken bones or grow back
missing bones
entirely lindford's next successful
potion was the pepper
potion a cure for the common cold that
helps to warm the recipient up
provided that linford was so successful
in his field it should come as no
surprise that the potter family lineage
continued to follow in his footsteps
next in line it was fleemont potter
harry's grandfather and james's dad who
continued to invent potions and rake in
the cash
fleemont never met harry but he did live
long enough to make
and leave him enough gold for a lifetime
fleemont took the family fortune
and quadrupled it by creating the famous
sleek easy's
hair potion so all of this should answer
the question of harry's wealth
but now what i want to discuss is did he
keep it all
was he still wealthy by the end of the
deathly hallows or
did he manage to spend it let's take a
look the state of harry's fortune is
mentioned numerous times throughout the
books
starting with the chamber of secrets
harry said nothing
he felt a bit awkward stored in an
underground vault gringotts in london
was a small fortune that his parents had
left him of course
it was only in the wizarding world that
he had money you couldn't use galleons
sickles and cannots in muggle shops he
had never mentioned his gringotts bank
account to the dursleys
he didn't think their horror of anything
connected with magic would stretch to a
large pile of gold
and it quickly becomes clear that as
early as the chamber of secrets
harry felt guilty about the piles of
gold in his vault
harry felt even worse when they reached
his vault he tried to block the contents
from view
as he hastily shoved handfuls of coins
into a leather bag
next harry's gold is mentioned in the
prisoner of azkaban
once harry had refilled his money bag
with gold galleons silver sickles and
bronze canuts from his vault at
gringotts
he needed to exercise a lot of
self-control not to spend the whole lot
at once
he had to keep reminding himself that he
had five years to go at hogwarts and how
it would feel to ask the dursleys for
money for spell books
as early as the prisoner of azkaban it
appears that harry is being smart with
his finances
resisting the temptation to buy
everything even though he could afford
it
harry's not just a wizard he's a
financially savvy wizard
next his wealth is mentioned in the
goblet of fire when ron makes a bit of a
questionable comment regarding harry's
finances
the gold i gave you at the quidditch
world cup said ron the leprechaun gold i
gave you for my omni oculus
in the top box why didn't you tell me it
disappeared
harry had to think for a moment before
he realized what ron was talking about
oh he said the memory coming back to him
at last
i don't know i never noticed it had gone
i was more worried about my wand wasn't
i
they climbed the steps into the entrance
hall and went into the great hall for
lunch
must be nice ron said abruptly when they
had sat down and started serving
themselves roast beef in yorkshire
puddings
to have so much money you don't notice
the pocketful of galleons goes missing
and next when harry's wealth is
mentioned in the order of the phoenix
we see another glimpse of harry's
philanthropic side when he donates 1 000
galleons to the weasley twins
an important distinction to make here
however is that this was extra money
harry had won harry grinned he had
forced the weasley twins to take the
thousand gallons prize money he had won
in the triwizard tournament
to help them realize their ambition to
open a joke shop
but he was still glad to know that his
part in furthering their plans was
unknown to mrs weasley
she did not think running a joke shop
was a suitable career for two of her
sons
next as far on as the half-blood prince
harry's fortune is mentioned once again
when bill weasley passes harry a bag of
his own gold
bill who would be staying at home with
fleur much to hermione and ginny's
pleasure
passed a full money bag across the table
to harry where's mine
demanded ron at once his eyes wide
that's already harry's idiot
said bill i got it out of your vault for
you harry
because it's taking about five hours for
the public to get to their gold at the
moment
the goblins of titan security so much
thanks bill said harry pocketing his
gold and finally
harry's gold is mentioned once more in
the final book harry potter and the
deathly hallows
however in this quote it is only alluded
to
not mentioned specifically gringotts had
seemed a place of wonder that day
the enchanted repository of a trove of
gold he had never known he possessed
and never for an instant could he have
dreamed that he would return to steel
but within seconds they were standing in
the vast marble hall of the bank
harry however didn't come to steal gold
it turns out he still had plenty of that
so in conclusion how much gold did harry
have left by the end of the book
film series i don't have an exact amount
but it was enough that he barely noticed
a dent
in the tremendous pile we're introduced
to in the philosopher's stone
as late as the half-blood prince harry
still had bags of gold to spare
and i think this is largely because over
the course of his life
things always seem to be given to him
it's a classic case of the rich
just getting richer and that's it for
this video
did you guys know how harry got rich did
you ever wonder about the state of his
finances
after the first film let me know in the
comment section
below until next time as much money in
life as you could want
the two things most human beings would
choose above all
the trouble is humans do have a knack of
choosing precisely those things
that are worst for them
[Music]
do
you